a cidade é a maior invenção da
humanidade a sua o seu protagonismo hoje
não não se discute ainda mais no mundo
que mais de 50% da população é urbana
afinal as pessoas sempre sentirão
necessidade de fazer contatos de estarem
multidões de novidades
enfim de se transformar
não é por outro motivo que 100 pessoas
não existe cidade
da mesma forma que sem transformação uma
cidade não sobrevive não evolui podendo
inclusive fale ou até mesmo sucumbe um
exemplo nesse sentido é de uma cidade
norte americana de detroit que pô que
foi outrora a meca da indústria
automobilística norte americana e por
não saber ou por não ter conseguido se
transformar quando o seu parque
industrial foi às ruínas é hoje
considerada a segunda legislação daquele
país uma cidade falida
se essa cidade por pelo seu lado ainda
não está conseguindo achar uma forma de
como agir para se transformar a pequena
santa rita do sapucaí uma cidade
localizada no sul de minas já está se
reinventando através de uma ampla
mobilização das forças locais através de
um movimento chamado cidade criativa
cidade feliz com cerca de 40 mil
habitantes esta cidade respira
tecnologia e empreendedorismo para que a
gente possa entender toda a agitação que
essa cidade está passando neste momento
toda euforia toda transformação da
cidade
nós vamos buscar na no livro de sua
história três episódios que marcam o
processo de transformação dessa cidade
até chegar nos dias de hoje
o primeiro ocorre a primeira referência
é quando a tecnologia chegou nessa
cidade
a tecnologia chegou nessa cidade em 1959
na mesma época que uma escola de
eletrônica a primeira da américa latina
foi inaugurada ainda seguindo essa mesma
trilha alguns anos depois é inaugurado
um instituto de ensino superior
chamado inatel que trabalha com
engenharia de telecomunicações que
também foi pioneiro na sua área
bom com essas duas instituições
de uma certa forma estava selada a a
trajetória dessa cidade a partir daí era
uma trajetória todinha estruturada em
tecnologia e tudo ia muito bem
é inclusive a cidade parecia que tinha
uma sina de ser um local de formação de
mão de obra especializada para as
grandes empresas
mas quando chega na década de 80 uma
crise forte que se abate sobre o país
muda radicalmente a história dessa
cidade
isso porque grande parte dos jovens que
formavam lá não tiveram mais ao mesmo a
mesma facilidade de emprego que tinha
até então foi aí então que começou a se
desenhar uma segunda transformação na
cidade que foi a junção da tecnologia
com o empreendedorismo se não havia
empregos fora porque não criar os
empregos dentro da cidade
foi com esse moto que a cidade se
reorganizou e começou a estimular esses
jovens a criar na cidade suas próprias
empresas
então a dificuldade do emprego se
transformou na oportunidade de fazer com
que esses jovens passassem de futuros
empregados a donos dos seus próprios
negócios
então nós tivemos aí uma reorganização
da cidade uma reorganização da parte
urbana da cidade e o produto disso após
três décadas mais ou menos é que hoje a
cidade tem 153 empresas de base
tecnológica a maioria delas no setor de
eletrônica e telecomunicações
essas empresas faturaram o ano passado
cerca de 2.72 de reais
elas oferecem cerca de 10 mil empregos e
exporta para 40 países
nesse nesta euforia de crescimento da
cidade
surge então uma marca da cidade que é o
vale da eletrônica
fica muitas vezes hoje não se fala santa
rita se fala vale da eletrônica e essa
marca ela se coloca a cidade em pé de
igualdade com grandes centros de
tecnologia no mundo inteiro
porém ao longo do tempo mesmo
considerando um primeiro período de
grande desenvolvimento da cidade de
grande crescimento dessa parte produtiva
da cidade
notou se que esse espírito inovador
esse espírito atrevido da cidade
começava a entrar numa fase de
acomodação foi então que começaram a a
as lideranças locais começaram a se
preocupar se realmente aquele seria o
destino da cidade
e aí foi então que começaram a olhar
para a cidade e perceberam que a cidade
tinha se transformado que a cidade tenha
se modificado e uma das modificações
mais visíveis é que a população urbana
da cidade tinha ganhado um componente
novo havia uma população que tinha sido
atraída para a cidade
desses empresários desses micro
empresário que agora estava convivendo
com as pessoas da cidade e essa prova
essa população tinham seios expectativas
diferentes demandas diferente e uma
delas era exatamente que a cidade
tivesse uma vida cultural mais
movimentada mais ativa e que também
oferecesse mais opções de lazer
começava a se desenhar e uma uma
terceira transformação da cidade que
desta vez ao invés de ser em cima de
realizações tangíveis como uma escola ou
como uma empresa notou se que precisava
de mexer com as pessoas
precisava de é a da 19 um novo
direcionamento para as pessoas no
sentido de a a aproximar essas pessoas
mais a cidade
foi dessa forma que então surgiu há um
movimento na cidade chamado movimento
cidade criativa cidade feliz
a base desse movimento era para que o
processo de transformação da cidade
acontecesse
através da mobilização das pessoas em
torno desses novos temas que era cultura
criatividade e inovação
o movimento cidade criativa cidade feliz
ele é um movimento criativo colaborativa
organizado de forma aberta e distribuída
sem nenhuma chance ela oficial e sem
também nenhuma liderança isolada que
comande o movimento essa foto essa foto
ilustra muito bem os personagens desse
movimento e essa foto ela está sempre em
constante transformação porque sempre
está chegando mais gente para o
movimento a a forma como esse movimento
entendia que deveria trabalhar
era uma forma através de festivais
esse foi o modelo ou foi a estratégia
que se esse adotou para que o as ações
de mobilização da comunidade pudesse
acontecer
então o primeiro festival foi realizado
em 2013
mas esse festival ele não era um
festival convencional ele não era um
festival de um tema único na realidade
ele era um festival composto de vários
festivais onde temas de criatividade de
cultura de inovação e de
empreendedorismo enfim de vários temas
pudesse aparecer
de tal maneira que se pudesse mexer com
a comunidade como um todo infelizmente
esse primeiro festival
a receptividade não foi exatamente como
a que nós esperávamos mas por outro lado
ele não se viu como base e parâmetro
para planejar o próximo festival que foi
o de 2014 em 2014 com mais gente
engajada
nós tivemos uma resposta da comunidade
bem diferenciada e aí nos animou
inclusive a fazer com que o festival de
uma semana do ano anterior
mas assis e de um mês e nesse mês de
atividades
as atividades foram tão intensa então o
sucesso foi tão grande que algumas
dessas atividades foram estendidas para
o ano todo
a ideia era transformar o movimento é
que estava sendo conhecido na cidade
pelos festivais em uma o que a gente
chama de uma usina de idéias criativas
que funcionasse
de forma permanente e ininterrupta foi
dessa forma que a partir de 2014
o movimento começou a se relacionar com
a cidade nós temos algumas atividades
desse evento é que a gente destaca pela
importância que elas tiveram como por
exemplo essa atividade que é o rock de
rua
o hopi o rock de rua o que ele é
foi uma atividade para fazer o resgate e
também para proporcionar aos músicos
locais e de fora que faz que fazem
músicas autorais tivesse um local para
mostrar o trabalho
o resultado dessa experiência foi tão
positivo que a cidade hoje está se
tornando um pólo de produção de música
autoral
então não só um evento de lazer um
evento musical mas também com o impacto
econômico na cidade
essas atividades no entanto nos deram um
nos deram a certeza de que era preciso
que é possível sim em poder às pessoas e
que o empoderamento das pessoas
ele automaticamente aumenta a
auto-estima das pessoas e as pessoas
sentindo mais ou não só a autoestima
como também o sentimento de
pertencimento das pessoas
as pessoas sentindo mais pertence duas
elas se transformam e as pessoas
transformadas elas transformam a cidade
essa é a lógica que nós nós conseguimos
perceber a foto mostra por exemplo uma
pessoa simples que no um dos projetos
nós que era de muro de rua de pintar
muro de rua ela sentiu pertence da
cidade a partir do momento que foi dada
a ela uma oportunidade de participar
aí então veio o terceiro festival que
aconteceu esse ano que acontece sempre
no mês de agosto é e nós entendemos que
agora considerando todo o crescimento do
festival
nos dois anos anteriores o festival
tinha que ser mais diversificado tinha
que ser mais agressivo tinha que ser
mais atrevido tinha que ser mais
inspirador porque ele precisava de mim
tá esse momento em que as pessoas
estavam mudando a relação dela com a
cidade
e aí a estratégia que adotou se nesse
evento desse ano foi de combinar fazer a
a todas as atividades combinadas de
forma que a gente tivesse combinações
inusitadas e provocações inusitadas que
pra nós chamamos tanto uma quanto outra
de combinações criativas e provocações
criativas por combinações criativas nós
entendemos por exemplo esse caso aí foi
um filho foi um evento musical que foi
apresentado neste festival que é um
musical já bastante conhecido que o réu
e que ele foi todo reorganizado e foi
feita uma combinação de música de dança
de música clássica com música popular e
se fechou esse evento foi o que encerrou
o festival deste ano de uma forma
extraordinária
outra combinação que foi feita era por
exemplo combinar palestra com show
musical
outra combinação era combinar ginástica
por exemplo com música e até mesmo aula
com música o filosofia e tantas outras
combinações criativas que a gente
organizou neste meio de festival e por
provocações nós entendemos que a
provocação significa você é trabalhar
com o tradicional de uma forma diferente
significa você desafiar o tradicional à
saída da sua da sua área de conforto e
aí tem o caso nós vamos mostrar dois
casos aqui
o primeiro foi de um festival de jazz e
música e blue que venha sendo oferecido
nesse evento desde o primeiro evento e
que nesse ano nós desafiamos os
organizadores do do vale music a não só
trazer o festival como todo mundo
conhece mas apresentar conteúdos e
formas de palestras e um workshop
o resultado mais uma vez foi
surpreendente o público foi recorde ea
gente tinha uma expectativa contida
porque afinal de contas não é um gênero
tão popular assim mas o resultado foi
extraordinário não só de gente da cidade
como também de gente de fora
a outra provocação criativa que nós
tivemos que foi também de um grande
impacto foi um evento que nós
organizamos chamado startup z o strata
pisei na realidade é um status weekend
mas para um público infantil para
crianças de 11 a 15 anos
vocês não conseguem imaginar o que essas
crianças conseguiram fazer em dois dias
de atividades
reunimos cerca de 300 crianças tivemos
várias idéias várias idéias que chegará
planos de negócio e fi
isso nos mostrou que essa geração tem
muito a ensinar tanto para nós como pais
como para professores
isso tudo nos dava uma certeza de que o
que a gente imaginava estava de fato
acontecendo
ou seja o que a gente estava fazendo era
uma provocação é uma perturbação no
espaço dos iguais que são as nossas
casas que agora a partir de toda essa
movimentação passava a ter uma
concorrência com o espaço dos diferentes
que são as ruas e praças da cidade como
produto como ganho como conquista desses
três anos já de atividade intensa é a
gente já começa a observar que há uma um
aumento do sentimento de pertencimento
das pessoas que a gente pode observar
quando alguém chega e se oferece pra
organizar um evento e diz que se tá
fazendo aquilo que está contagiada pelo
pelo movimento
outros são outras consequências são os
negócios criativos que começaram a
surgir esse café artesanal como café
artesanal talvez ele não tenha não seja
uma coisa tão original assim mas tem um
segundo momento desse café original que
isso sim trouxe um diferencial da mesma
forma como nós vimos uma uma bike café
ali embaixo e se esse empresário que
também criou o café a partir de da
influência dos festivais de atividades
do festival mais começou criou
uma bicicleta também declarou balbi food
café né e que ela serve além de café
drinques à base de café
nós também tivemos podemos constatar
hoje que tem uma que a arte ea cultura
ela passa ela passou a ter um papel
muito importante ela entrou no cotidiano
da cidade tanto arte cultura como também
a economia criativa de tudo isso nós
temos quatro argumentos que nos dá a
certeza de que a gente está no caminho
certo
o primeiro argumento é que é preciso é
articular as forças da cidade governo é
instituições e empresas porque sem uma
um fortalecimento dessas relações
é muito difícil a gente promover uma
cidade é levar uma cidade é um nível
superior ao nível de cidade criativa
inovadora e até mesmo feliz como o nosso
como está escrito no nosso movimento
a outra com a outra outra certeza que
realmente conexões é que mudam a cidade
mais conexões feitas por pessoas mas por
pessoas movidas não apenas por um
sentimento coletivo mas sobretudo um
sentimento colaborativa e por último que
pessoas a certeza que nós temos hoje é
que pessoas são os monumentos em
movimento e isso significa que se a
gente olhar pra esse movimento e souber
interferir nesse movimento na hora que
for necessária para corrigi lo e levá lo
a um estado de maior de maior sucesso de
maior organização da cidade
nós estaríamos então conseguindo fazer
uma cidade com mais felicidade de tudo
isso que eu falei fica então a minha
mensagem final que temos que tornar as
mudanças dentro de nós nós somos os
agentes de mudança nós estamos fazendo
isso milhares de cidades estão fazendo
isso como aqui está fazendo e eu
proponho e sugiro que todos nós
continuamos nesse caminho muito obrigado